seaweed is something you might try to
avoid at the beach but a team of
researchers from the Sunshine Coast
thinks it could be queensland's next Big
Industry a trial of seaweed farming off
the southeast Queensland Coast is
showing promising results
in moreton Bay an oyster Farm is trying
something new
seaweed
we farmed about 125 kilograms of seaweed
or around 10 000 sushi rolls were small
plants are put into Nets and attached to
Oyster lines growing into a floating
Forest of seaweed sausages in a joint
project between the University of the
Sunshine Coast and water provider Urban
utilities it's quite tough to grow
oysters it takes around about three
years and with climate change and
increasing water temperatures there's a
lot more risk of operation around
disease so they were really Keen to see
if they could diversify into other
products it could be queensland's next
Big Industry used for more than just
Sushi we know that seaweed can be fed to
cattle there's even people exploring its
use in sustainable packaging so Plastics
the 30 million tons of seaweed is
produced worldwide each year and
forecasts show Australia has the
potential for a billion dollar industry
within the next two decades the two-year
trial has had environmental benefits too
for every ton of wet seaweed that we're
pulling from the bay we're pulling out
about one and a half kilos of nitrogen
as well it remains to be seen whether
large-scale seaweed farming would be
commercially viable in moreton Bay but
from Little Things big things grow
Elizabeth crumsey ABC News